hello everybody and welcome to another
episode of Rand cafe here at Anime
uproar my name is Anna Mack I mean it's
not really but that's what I call myself
and this is episode 24 of Rand cafe and
this in this episode we're going to be
talking about do shounen anime suck and
if so how much
conclusion they do not yeah we decided
in disguise good good to see you Tony
we're here with bread for Brent's
fandoms we're here with bricks from
all-day anime cyanide blizzard from
cyanide blizzard and Tony from black
critic guy hey everybody
hello hello hello so i'ma pull Sinai
blizzard today I don't have my camera so
oh yeah I'm just I'm gonna tell you just
like [ __ ] he's no no I'm wearing sure
I promise breaks I promise that's the
geology Aoyama in all over and that's
what we're talking about today voice yep
finally get him a dress yeah I
definitely particularly excited for this
episode and we're gonna definitely all
day so how many adverts you're gonna use
Briggs definitely particularly exactly
Mitch absolutely absolutely yes and we
might also have Mac and a special guest
joining us
perhaps potentially we don't know later
on but [ __ ] might go down just randomly
people like outfits so you know be be
prepared be prepared but in the meantime
what we're gonna be doing in this
episode is basically talking about Shona
first of all let's talk about how do you
define show that in the sense of shorten
is a demographic so it refers to you
know young boys and animate geared
towards young boys however what we've
tend to now use to describe like you
know we use shorten to describe a
certain type of anime that is geared
towards younger boys but that is also
has a very specific sort of um I guess
archetype where you know an underdog
starts to fight his way to the top in
some way finds a bunch of friends and
through the power of friendship triumphs
and after 800 episodes
something is potentially achieved where
we can I can I just can I make a
statement real quick did you honestly
title this video does Shonen anime suck
yes you try to trigger everybody in this
in this discussion panel ah extremely
short yes it's good fighting words I'm
leavin I'm leavin I can't hate you
anyway anime uproar they're here to get
to the facts you know do Shonen anime
suck that's a good question to ask you
need to be uh well here's a better
question why does cyanide blizzardy what
a cyanide well you know you know it's a
really good question you know what's up
with you hatin on Toni Toni with an eye
because it's fancier who runs a channel
called BGC black critic guy you know why
why do you you know black guy critic
actually sorry see there you go I'm
already calling your channel name you
know this guy critiques men happens to
be black and then you go and you create
black Critic guy and you ruin his
channel you ruin his reputation you ruin
homes
you're just a bad influence Tony with
why well I get you know that song hide
your kids hide your wife that's actually
based on a true incident including
myself so uh I will reiterate that
that's whole statement but back to what
Anna Mac mentioned about Shonen anime
buddy anime ello animal you're on you're
me you want to be there
I stick way to you oh wow Briggs okay
you take it he's bad Briggs as you can
tell I am a very large fan of Shonna and
me and we're definitely gonna hear a lot
of like cons like a negative towards
from the enemy from adamak and they're
absolutely are especially when you get
into long-running shonan's
but I'd like to point out that not all
show names are long-running and you can
find a good amount of short ones that
are achieved with the long back
not always your crude equal it's true
that is true rune you need a
get that hashtag trending right now
hashtag not all shonan's please not
Shannon you got a bad hashtag all showed
you on hashtag recon no Pico no no havoc
no pico buddy havoc no ego
so much everybody it's crazy and I see
them in the chat I see some usual
suspects I see neo geo la digue the enol
deep-voiced the anime dude
sassy simone and anime recon recon Oh
Pecola top bro we have silent killer
penguins burn ready what's up man oh of
course on Buddha the moderator and also
mega anime openings he didn't seen him
in the discord what's up bro oh and by
the way guys all of you here
discord party this Sunday May 7th all
day discord party you are only wanted
make an appearance we want you there
people are asking about you mostly Brinn
but the rest of you are just as well
wait a minute why they ask you about
grid what about me will bring us great
antenna then actually join us for a
lovely kataoka session in the past and
she is quite me did oh I didn't know we
were doing karaoke I love to sing hello
I got them set up the voice of a
baritone sexy man come on
well done you wrong did you not hear
what sing to Lenny let's do it
did you not hear me sing the Ponyo theme
song it was magnificent yeah well
actually yeah we do cut okay every week
Tony I mean weekend so that's what I'm
saying man you got to drop in you gotta
say it tell the fans that you appreciate
it all right well then I will I'll drop
in and dethrone that do that do it with
Brynn Sunday be there we'll pick out
thank you son we'll pick a song that's
probably what you picked the song action
game I've added song choices we'll take
a like a song that nobody's heard about
and I'm singing they're like we don't
really
this song well it's gotta be a fun time
guys I'm telling you we're we crossed
1,000 members on this Court I think
we're like a thousand twenty-something
now which is not so yeah it's a crazy
community over there really fun really
proud of everyone over there the
moderators the Knights you know I love
you guys and everyone else was there
taking apart even the trolls like you
guys give us something to do put you
timeouts and ban you and you know we
love you you you give us your sacrament
cause it's always you know what
different timeout we banned you yeah
it's an ecosystem right you need all
that kind of love right yeah all pie so
make it function so yeah it's good
anyway uh Anna Mac back to showing an
enemy oh look at all anywhere this
professional sudo is trying to get back
on topic cheese well I mean it's an
interesting thing you say you don't
you're you're not particularly fond of
Shonen anime which I find interesting
since that flag behind you is from a
shounen anime and I believe you once
said that that's your favorite anime
correct it is it is however the point is
what is shown in how do we define Shana
that's the thing because yes there is
anime where they're geared towards there
are enemy that are geared towards
younger men such as for example Death
Note people some people would say it's
Shonen because it was I believe in
Shonen Jump right but then that's not
necessarily what I consider shown and
when I say shown in colloquial e what I
mean is you're you know these cookie
cutter anime where you have an underdog
and he you know he's a crybaby and then
he ends up becoming making friends and
doing all these things like I realized
with Gurren Lagann it has aspects of
that but it also subverts it with the
whole yeah but that's not that unique
totally Miserables you totally
misrepresented as shown showed shown in
anime back in the 90s that description
would not have fly except for maybe Neon
Genesis because one piece
Dragon Ball Z yuu-yuu hakusho hunter x
hunter none of them have main
protagonists that are crybabies then
either close I mean I wouldn't define it
I'll go ahead Bridge out say I wouldn't
define it more as like cry bury and the
main character has to be an underdog per
se like in like hold like the like the
way you're using it anyway but for
example one piece even though Luffy
isn't exactly an underdog in like from
the start he's always been overall like
pretty strong and great other people but
his overall goal and aspirations put
them in an underdog situation so it's
it's not just play a crybaby weak
protagonist they get stronger but
sometimes their goals and aspirations
put them in an underdog scenario well I
get where animatic is coming from with
that you know it's in Tony you brought
you brought up a really good point there
from a Western audience perspective
obviously as nmuk mentioned before we we
refer to show not as a demographic but
as this particular type of genre and
Western wise it's generally associated
with a long-running shows about a about
a young male character having to
overcome almost insurmountable
objectives and always being able to do
so primarily so it's just you know
builds usually upon that very very
fast-paced with action with also large
periods of downtime associated heavily
with filler as well I know that I think
that's a really um good point to touch
upon as well maybe not necessarily cry
baby per se but there's I mean they're
characters that are overcoming a lot of
obstacles and in some cases depending
upon the show can be also associated
with a degree nutsert that's really of
crybaby but angst which I guess could be
associated with it as such so I get
where he's coming from with that of
course uh Briggs you made a good point
earlier not all Shonen are the same
that's really important to consider that
as well uh Luffy was a great example
there you know he's definitely not like
that at all so uh Naruto I'm another
example where you know he's he comes
from you know fight against the odds and
he's sort of got this never give up
attitude about it so you know mainly
over the years they changed a lot of
that but sorry Tony oh no I was just
saying if anything that the character
type I think would better define a
shounen anime or eccentric male leads
Goku why luffy naruto ichigo to a
certain extent although he just seems
very apathetic to things but that would
be awesome that i think that's
much more accurate description I don't
say it's the the overall encompassing
description because the thing about
Shonen is that it is basically a
demographic it's not a description of a
genre because there are different things
in Shonen that don't necessarily fit
into what is the proceed notion of
Shonen like that like I vege I I'll go
ahead brick so I keep on cutting you off
man go ahead no no no I I decided to be
cut off cuz I'm removing yogasana right
now oh yeah it's true how about I cut
you anyone oh you uh you got my chance
at Fame my chance at Fame sign I'd I
could have been famous I know I'm sorry
some questions we will will reconnect
okay okay okay so to get back on track
NeoGeo brings up a good point he says
that a lot of Shonen can have sane and
elements in them and I agree the thing
is when I say go I guess
generic Shonen is what my problem is
with personally and yeah you know Shauna
can be done right if it has some kind of
like interesting element that's unique
that makes it special but my problem is
when they're just very generic so the
types of generic Shauna that I would
describe would be and stuff like Naruto
stuff like my hero academia stuff like
oh that's those are some Bowl that's a
bold statement to make right now it is
but it is it is very generic and it's a
same thing with like Eureka Seven like
you have your classic sort of underdog
crybaby character a slow pacing pacing
that's just such a pain because it takes
forever to get to I need a piece yeah
like like that's my issue like so for
sure and I'd have to think a lot of
episodes usually is is generic shown and
they'll have a lot of episodes because
they're very popular
they'll be have slow build-up slow
pacing a crybaby protagonist that I
really don't relate to so that would be
my question is once once you move beyond
the sort of teen angst years and you're
an adult as I think all of us here are
is there a point on the North in
watching these generic as shown in that
you can't necessarily relate to
anymore because you've moved beyond that
so like you you know you're looking for
different characters more mature
characters relate to not like Deku from
my hero academia actually might actually
relate a lot to him so I take I take
personal offense a sign ID for your
comment there so we're agreeing disagree
I want to hear what Bryn has to say yeah
I think that like Shonen like we've
discussed is it's like it's not a
category it is a category but it's not
like mostly most shonan's that we just
categorize it as our action like
adventure sometimes fantasy anime it's
not necessarily it's it's geared towards
that type of audience like a young male
audience but I don't think that it's
only supposed to be for young male
audiences like I enjoy shonan's quite a
bit there's not a lot long-running ones
that I'm super big fan of but like the
shorter ones I really like them a lot
but I I do actually invest into these
like young boy characters that are like
growing and developing and trying to
like overcome whatever it is kind of
like an underdog story but it's it all
depends on the character I think NMX
problem is that he just doesn't like
crybabies which to be fair there are
some crybabies within shonan's but not
all of course like I think if we're
that's putting it too much into a mold
too much into a cookie cutter that like
it have to be a crybaby I think it's
more like they have a journey and they
have something to accomplish and it's
not really right exactly it's not about
the crybaby aspect it's about growing so
agree and disagree on that you want to
see you want to see a crybaby I'll give
you an example watch chaos head there's
a crime in know one character boku no
hero academia is not a crybaby he's a
man placed in the terrible situation
that dreamed of being a hero was not
able to become a hero and then it's
reciting a little baby because he wasn't
a speck quite like a little bit if
someone told you I was some work guys I
don't have a queer because you were told
that you couldn't be something as a
child what you wouldn't cry about that
well someone told me a child if someone
told me that I couldn't be a singer as a
kid I would have bowled my eyes out that
would have been devastating and he
doesn't remain a crybaby and he's picked
on he's picked on constantly because
he's the only kid in his class that
doesn't have a power so his emotional
response to a situation makes a lot of
sense adamak now in a situation like
let's give Gurren Lagann a chance um
[ __ ] who's the main character Gurren
Lagann what was his name again soon the
little [ __ ] C Mon C Mon or AC mo I
can't like his little crybaby status I
mean it doesn't even come from my
personal growth you just kind of
pathetic most of the time and he latches
on to UM
kameena who is the exuberant personality
and kind of helps him break out of the
shell but his growth there is not
indicative of his situation his
situation was [ __ ] and was constantly
[ __ ] whereas the main character boku no
hero was placed in a situation where he
had the potential to reach something was
denied it and they made fun of it for it
so again his emotional responses to
what's happening to him is justified you
know saying makes no sense whatsoever no
cell really I came all Johnny
Simone Thank You Brent Simone lives in a
horrible situation he's taught to be
subservient to live in a hole in the
ground not to question and he's always
like this until coming up brings him out
of his shell and by the way he's also a
kid like I like Simone's like okay so so
it's okay if Simone cries because he's a
kid but the character but [ __ ] they did
okay cry with with it ten episodes
Simone gets his [ __ ] together it doesn't
take him eighty or twenty or however why
look at about the line and I suppose why
is that qu and sorry snore libro but I'm
just being honest
why is Debbie being honest after he
after he gets for no reason whatsoever
is now favored by the most
our hero and gets the most powerful
quirk no reason once a [ __ ] oh no
reason or do you watch the show are you
talking out of your ass
Oh technical potential from being a hero
you're not being polite you're not
letting me sorry
going episode I go tonight two episodes
ago
Deku was crying like a little [ __ ]
again
and even even all Mike was like why are
you crying again get your [ __ ] together
man [ __ ] is a little Watterson but then
he says like no I thought your weakness
I thought that was your weakness the
fact that you are crying at cetera like
you're weak but that's actually your
strength that's the one thing that's
going to make you a better hero like and
it's not saying that like you crying is
a great thing it's like you understand
and you like connect with people you
feel like you are like in the situation
you understand the fight Manik but just
I just realized this is the first this
is the first ever real rant cafe were
actually ranting I feel like that let's
let's make a note of this sign out he
put it on the board okay I was like the
point out that okay him being key is a
little bit of a crybaby
a little bit a little bit whiny I think
that's like kind of his character type
but using his like when he was five
years old in the doctor's office in
[ __ ] and saying that he was children
for no reason it's kind of stupid too
because he moved for power in a
defensive situation just on like
instinct that help someone when there
were adults and heroes around that
didn't move others like fear and I
thought was the quality he saw because
the power of a 1 for all like he's gonna
give you a unlimited strength so like
he's not looking for someone that's
strong he's looking for someone that has
the like characteristics like
emotionally and the personality of a
hero so one the a people into a hero
exactly but you gonna set them on the
physical like portals freaks you may be
proud really like its character type a
little bit the comic the comedic aspect
of the show is that he's whiny but when
it matters most he steps up you know
yeah but I've every generic shown in
house that I respect you Joan
that Kegel stuff I can be nice to guys
and laying every generic Shonen like I
refused by their interrelation the worst
offender is Renton Thurston from [ __ ]
America 7 oh my god I've never seen that
animate so uh no comment
oh god this is a lacking cinnamon Holmes
Erica 7 Erica 7 you I didn't know cuz I
called it you Rika 7 - so why did you
add the two didn't I know your games on
my why you so silent business is boomin
I know business is the rant cafe
business but what what I understand
about the whole Deku stuff is like first
of all like can we talk about the fact
that he takes a metal sheath and drops
in a landmine and that somehow magically
flies through the air like on a magic
carpet like Aladdin and beats everyone I
could show you the world magical mermaid
when like a MV of him like flying down
yeah now where did you last let your
heart decide
it was beautiful moment
it wasn't gone to a great place now
right and by the way soul maka showing
that often he doesn't know what he's
talking about he says deco is not a
generic Shorin character he is the most
generic Shona character saying that I
was good it was not good so maka whoa
just looks weird um but let's let's look
the most in there whatsoever finite
perspective here I mean it's I I do
agree in in certain aspects a lot of
shown in male protagonists have generic
qualities or tendencies to them but I
get that from a writing perspective as
you know in terms of generalizing for an
audience it's a way for the audience to
essentially a project themselves under
the character or to be relatable or
understandable I mean that's the thing
is usually when you talk to people in
the anime they can read they'll
reference a popular shown in series in
the reference a certain character and
they'll you know they'll talk about how
I got into the
oh and usually depending upon the person
if you listen to what they're talking
about there's certain elements behind
that that they were able to gravitate
towards and as a person that allowed
them to be pulled into the show as well
and I think that's a deck who has
similar aspects apply to him as well I
think that to two degrees we can relate
to that you know it's it is emotional
state fluctuates a lot more rapidly than
I would personally care for but I could
also empathize with that as well
you know it's it's an ordinary person in
fact actually is an abnormal person
placed in an extraordinary situation so
I mean it's just you know not only is he
a teenager which you know any teenager
male or female or regardless you know
you're at an emotional fluctuation
during that point your life we all are
it's you know just hormone imbalance
time but I mean it's also the unit
situation itself so it's sort of like a
double tandem there so I can I can
understand who would agree with in that
but I would necessarily discard what Ana
Mack is saying either in regard not like
I get that I get that and like yeah when
you're a teen and you're dealing with
difficult things and you're an underdog
in many ways and you're trying to like
persevere you will appreciate this type
of stuff but I feel like once you move
beyond that like you know what's gonna
happen like the worst thing in my near
academia the first thing is like this is
how I became the greatest hero of all
time so we already know the ending we
already know the [ __ ] ending but it's
not it's not a book it's a journey it's
not about the destination it's the
journey [ __ ] yeah that's like
every child child cartoon for Disney is
oh you know everything's gonna be fine
at the end but let's just have you know
a nice journey well that's it I was
warned what is what who is hero academia
geared towards teens correct that that's
that that's there Jen that's the
demographic oh yeah I think I think they
did a pretty good job at aiming at that
aiming right at the bullseye so yeah I
don't see a problem with that I was
annoyed by it too but I was annoyed in
the perspective of a storyteller
perspective I don't like giving away
reveals that way but yeah I thought the
point isn't about the destination it's
the journey the journey how he became
the greatest hero you know it anyway I
know I only
we know we all know Luffy is going to
find one piece it's not about him
finding it it's the journey to get to
one piece that's the most compelling
part of one piece because once he finds
it I mean oh we found it so what now
that Hitler read says bring best wife oh
I bet the best wife who just entered the
room right okay ladies and gentlemen
what's up bro oh good morning thank you
for joining us yes I'm sorry that
cyanide is here he ruins everything so I
know let me just find the rose welcome
back to my channel welcome back
oh thank you thank you again I'll just
point out that it's your channel ok nice
SEO news is that right you know yeah we
weren t oh this videos maybe people
don't get my reference they're black
critic guy Ferran Rose tell us how's
Korea how long you been there now it is
amazing I've been here for where's Jeff
wait Jeff every wife april/may take
three three months ish almost three
months
Wow it doesn't feel that long to me ya
thought it was like a month
hello longer than that so I'm happy it's
been a great time so far I'm just like
kind of asleep sixth oh man yeah I'll be
joining you I'll be joining you soon in
the Pacific actually so a fill your room
so fill you oh really
where are you going Tony I'm going back
to the lung whoo nice yes
nice land when July oh yeah if you want
a favor all right Patti will go to Korea
and we'll watch a bunch of shown in
watch out watch on Animax David shown in
a boku no hero academia season one and
two beautiful yes uh he really liked
that one part where um the main
character was crying that was his
favorite ha ha that was Bart just come
what time there
I really can't do anything oh good good
show good show but not my hero academia
I actually watch it it's not one of
those shows that I have to draw but
while I watch it I do have some
frustrations with it and that's I like
to talk about only there's some sure
they're so bad at I can't even like
watch but in this case it's a short
watch but I have personally tell me
about that what I said tell me about it
though bad anime is that you can't for
yet you can't even sit and watch you
want to Bamie
listen it was a sarcastic you know Rose
save me I'm about to kill vinolas how
much you like Lumpy's it's great love it
it's all over the place here you'll love
it here
one peacefully everywhere real yes
everywhere you turn there's one piece
everywhere oh wait I thought the stigma
is the stigma Japanese hate gone in
Korea now oh so much series stolen long
pieces transcends it but yeah I'm just
where is the date race I'm surprised
they embraced something that's Japanese
but to me that's interesting especially
learning they're a history with Japan so
yeah I don't know but one piece
apparently it was fine for them so one
pieces everywhere funny enough Briggs if
you come to Guam there's a one piece bus
thanks a yo-yo the whole time when there
be wouldn't it make more sense for it to
be like a gold yeah I mean it would be
anyway great to make a boat why did they
do that it's a good point thank you see
we can repair [ __ ] right
and by the way Luna wants me to notice
her Luna you have been noticed um so
yeah about the thing Tony about like
Japanese hate there due to World War two
and stuff I've some Chinese friends that
are super into anime and I asked them
the same type of thing and they
like you know their parents generation
still doesn't like the Japanese but like
the youths they mostly don't care yeah
that does a reason for that you know
they hadn't had this very superiority
complex and they said hey were the
superior Asians so [ __ ] you guys weren't
gonna sleep I'm surprised they enslaved
China that was interesting to me small
ass island took over that much land yeah
I hate God gotta be the dresser you know
and the Chinese were always like to make
your tonight oppressing me absolutely
the Chinese were pissed because of
course the Japanese got many things from
China including language so the Chinese
were actually you know the first
civilization that became truly great in
that part of world so it was like ah
their offspring taking them over and
that was a lot of resentment about that
like I said I was just surprised when
Rose told me that they have like you
know one piece all over the place there
um I I once saw talked to somebody when
I lived in Guam somebody loves Korean
that really hated Japanese people I'm
like War and they told me the history
I'm like oh that's it that is [ __ ]
nasty what they did well I think I'm
like I'm glad well to like you that it's
[ __ ] it's slowly shifting it that's a
nice paradigm and you know Japan kind of
calm down over the years and you know
they're all about that Kauai eNOS so if
they're dead if they're harmless now you
know are they go because yes they have
kawaii girls but they also have wound
concert a quest question mark question
mark question mark mark in question okay
that a lot of people don't like the idol
industry either so it's uh if I'm
correct isn't Korea
we're mainly responsible for that
epidemic right now palm idols there you
go see that's a it's an epidemic
it's sweeping the world yeah by the way
Albion asked if World War Two was the
best Shonen anime I don't know about
that
I guess your protagonist Oh some Italia
open this big cheese so roll
why do everyone Rose is back to making
regular videos now which we're all happy
about and Rose tell us what you're
thinking so far in terms of what you're
doing right now with your videos what
you're thinking about the future what
anime your liking only how much you like
my dear academia I haven't actually
caught up on I hear academia so no
pinyin yet on that I know I'm very sorry
Bradley but I'm sorry I'm sorry I will I
will catch up I have a lot of things to
do rather than shoujo cast I can't I cry
I want to do the Soviet past but um and
just been watching attack on Titan right
now and I have turned it into a live
stream reaction channel for attack on
Titan at the moment because I just don't
have time to sit and do a review instead
I just here's my thoughts here's a live
reaction there you go
so that's my channel that made sense
yeah dead yes mates role as much sense
don't diss that stop cuz I'm doing the
same thing right now everybody on you
and everybody else [ __ ] you to the
out bro next thing you know cyanide baby
I'm really enjoying attack on Titan
season 2 it's action-packed
it's building up to something big it's
like yeah like it's it's actually much
more interesting than my hero academia
right now by like leaps and bounds leaps
I mean who's gonna argue who's gonna
argue with you on that well and that's
it but that's my problem with my hero
academia in the first season too it
really got good in that final villains
attack arc but you have to wait like 10
episodes for that to happen I was like
why why do we have to wait build up we
gotta be invested right yeah I mean
there's this the whole thing of a
character development and oh your
character you okay in doing so you gotta
kind of spend time with them outside of
ARC's oh I mean oh yeah why do I have to
tell you this sign I should be telling
you this sign I hello
you in there sign I'd I guess we done
right yeah good be right back
oh wait sassy Simone says Yuri and ice
best Shonen and we all love this
yuria nice is best everything judging by
judging by [ __ ] crunchyroll Awards so
what is Fanny I don't know about the
best everything but I'll give that's
everything I'll give it some things
wait is that categorizes Shonen I don't
know well brand roses a Sports anime
doesn't mean it's not like a shounen so
well I guess I'll have to go do some
research you should go look it up by the
way God if you want to see someone freak
out like no one's business over Yuri oh
nice
please watch the featured video on Brinn
from Briggs fandoms channel I'll link in
the description I just when I was
looking for the link to her channel to
link it in the description because I was
like everyone's channel in the
description
it just started playing in us you should
you should have just linked that video
as my like subscribe like thing cuz then
they just see me like what the heck
yep oh yeah we saw so excited you guys
well although I said I have to be fair
when I talk about Gurren Lagann and [ __ ]
pretty much equal amount of fangirling
going on okay say we could have a
fangirl then off it hit me over urea
nice and you over gurren lagaan and then
just yeah see who wins in the guy I
think that would be quite quite a show i
I have to agree with you on that topic
yeah Bryn tell us what are some of the
biggest things you like about my hero
academia like convince me convince me
hmm well I mean a lot of it we've said
it's like it's about the journey that
Dec who goes on it
it's not about him like he had to start
somewhere and it's okay we got to see
his past that he was a crybaby but like
we've discussed it's the fact that he
like if that's a normal reaction
to cry when you're bullied as a child
you know some characters in some animes
like don't but that's a normal reaction
right but he goes on this beautiful
journey and it's about what's on the
inside guys and I know like I just said
it and I'm like barf too little my
mouth's that's so gross and cliched like
it's kind of true but when it's done
right like cliche is not bad when it's
done right and what's done in other way
and this is that in a good way you get
to understand his character and it's
almost like the predictability of it and
like you know the understanding of
course it's going to become a great hero
of course he's going to be with all my
cetera but that's kind of the fun part
of it is that you get to see that
actually like happen and progress and
build and grow and so that's what I like
about it you know it has those cliches
but it is done well so I don't mind it
at all I like a lot of course you're a
little done the black credit guys gonna
defend cliches that's all he doesn't
miss channel Oh shots fired
I guess you don't really watch my
channel as I attack cliches oh I get I
get called out because I'm so hard on
cliches no it's true Tony all your wish
I could share I'm like it is a cliche he
was doing he was doing a thing Tony's
being ironic Tony because tell me how do
you square your review of the latest
Fast and Furious film with your defense
of my hero academia because what what
Brin said cliches aren't bad in fact
they're unavoidable it's about the
approach it's about you do it you know
and how my hero academia takes the
cliches a fault and uses it to its
advantage and makes an entertaining
story whereas something like the fate of
the Furious or I'm sorry the figure the
Boreas takes the cliches do nothing with
it and say hey here have some fun now
and you're saying they're like no I'm
not gonna have fun with this go yeah I
agree with you like spruce saying the
first scene with the burning car I was
like I was already like oh man I can see
where this is going check I checked out
immediately I'm like well this
movies gonna test my patience now so I'm
done with you
yeah tell me how he didn't burn I mean
he was holding the [ __ ] wheel and his
hands weren't even burned are you
serious yeah I guess there are some
things we agree on sometimes man yeah
it's like it's like what mean sign I
used to be like you know when we agreed
on but we still have it you should
choose to run away from it by the ways I
do hate generic Shawn and drop a like on
this video because you agree with me if
you like generic Joan and drop a like on
this video because you agree with these
other guys so it's a win away movement
you may mention the boku no hero what's
another example of a of a generic shown
in in your opinion then um I guess with
Erica 7 it's not a generic setting but
it is a very generic protagonist
relationship with the rest of the world
and like his journey is very generic in
that sense arm I mean like Naruto is
generic now but it's an older so we can
give it a past it's kind of like in many
ways it's contributed to the trend um
like this is what it like for example if
we look at Evangelion right clearly a
crybaby protagonist
but it's adds an extra element of that
psychological philosophical element that
I could latch onto and really appreciate
even though I can relate to the main
character necessarily I don't I'm not
finding that in my hero academia for
example one punch man one punch man to
me is what you said Tony it tastes
cliches turns it on its head in a funny
way it's entertaining my hero academia
is like to me a lesser one punch man
wait wait did you just say that one
punch man took cliches do I own
ironically just say that it took me
Shay's and twisted it on its head
get [ __ ] I hate that argument and
it's such a [ __ ] terrible what in a
funny way so like there's nothing
there's nothing there's nothing Turk
there's no subverting when your last few
episodes is literally like every other
Sherman what's so burning about that the
first week so it uses
when his videos are squirt that was a
true parody episode on the guy is not
your generic the protagonist not your
genetic generic high-school student he's
a grown up me okay no generic high
school student he's a generic hero
character however don't tell me him
running in don't tell me him running in
at the last minute and saving everybody
doesn't sound like others shown in
action anime but ya know there's a leash
a piece one piece Dragon Ball Z I mean
we the list can go on not a lot of thing
where they find that what oh Michael not
making a face
that's right Mac the attentions on you
now Oh what are we talkin about hey Mac
yes talk about that sweet tattoo on your
arm we don't do that [ __ ] on this
channel bro do what lock down your house
and all your roommates aren't home
that's what I did but no Tony Tony at
airhorns acquired my ear span actually
uses cliches in a humorous way like it's
funny my zone is just funny to do lines
acting like every other shown that's
funny to you and that's not funny then
you know on a sense of humor my friend
which which bothers the mindset you did
like school rumbles I don't know what's
wrong with you nope why are you being
sarcastic I'm what I'm Bren help me out
I'm lost what happened
you're the rock of the truth bro can't
handle I I'm late what I'm so lost
yeah but that's what I do I love speak
of you own and not the clay stays in one
punch man aren't funny the first three
episodes yeah that was funny but the
problem with one punch man it's always
the biggest problem I have is that it's
it relies on one one solid premise
Saitama is overpowered and the problem
with that is that runs thin really fast
after episode 4 I was just like that's
that's kind of boring now can we do
something fun and I thought
we're gonna like take the other
characters and try to do something
humorous with them and sometimes they
did but other times they took them way
too seriously like I shown in action
enemy I couldn't believe that the final
climax of the move of the show felt like
any other action shown in where they're
basically all fighting this one bad guy
that came to earth and it's like this
overly long action scene with no humor
to it I'm like where's the funny thing
in here like the one funny thing in that
my climactic battle is when Saitama
makes that blank face that was funny but
that's it that's all the humor you get
from that sure just end it off on a gag
so yeah you don't would have been funny
you are be funny like if they showed up
and the guy that he was about to fight
is this little pipsqueak he's like the
strongest warrior in the world and I'm
just like that's funny because if it's a
giant alien with big muscles [ __ ] come
on man really are we doing sell all of a
sudden now is this like it really
oh it's dope but I'm just saying like
that's not a cybersyn that's following
the trend I think did you bro put it
best when he was talking about
subversion and anime and how most people
got it wrong and he point out how you
know one punch man isn't subversion at
all especially since it falls all those
trends I don't know each man made me
laugh but that's just me sorry yeah one
portrayal was funny my hero Lina is not
really funny but that's digit goal can
you play on an ace one one punch man one
punch man you supposed to be funny
unloading are always an action anime not
a comedy enemy so don't mix up the John
with Sarah just say boy dad no it's not
are you kidding me one punch man is also
action enemy like you're you're just an
action anime production have some straws
Tori the amount of drugs I'm grasping at
how am i grabbing at straws the whole
point the whole point of one punch man
was supposed to be a satire supposed to
be a comedy parody of action and it just
does everything that every other action
anime does in a funny way
No yes what you look good though
mom cycle 100 though I really enjoyed
this high five to that that's how you do
an overpower character right mob cycle a
slow devote much man with no money here
LMG physically not about the challenge
physically it's about the challenge on a
personal level that's what made mob such
an interesting character and why Saitama
fails as an interesting character cuz
personally he's been knocking over me so
I can say something code yes mom okay
thank you thank you
Saitama is a hilarious character
consecutive normal punches was hilarious
the whole concept even the OVA s with
the fries were super funny
jenos is a hilarious character the
dynamic is hilarious it's a funny to fly
the [ __ ] fly is funnier than anything
that's ever going to happen in my hero
academia and the reason I keep comparing
it to is because they're both very
similar world a heroes Association
superheroes as a job right so that's why
I bring that up and to me one punch man
does a much better job it's much more
entertaining you can expect I hear
academia the math one punch man in
comedy is my hero about the comedy
obviously you must be like what is your
name
and to me one butch weight is much more
entertaining regardless of the genre did
you not hear what I said earlier I said
the first three episodes of one punch
man which includes that episode about
the fly and stuff or funny
that's subversion but after episode four
when they introduced a hero League and
then they have the whole big battles and
all that stuff
that's where I was just like oh man
another really fun emoji my laughs why
would you want to have AI want them to
make fun of the big battles like the one
of the funniest things even though they
try to play it seriously so remember all
remember Mouton Rider
ah to the battle to fight that giant
like a blizzard monster and everyone's
cheering for him booted rider Mouton
Rider and he's just women they were
doing that whole thing were like the
hero has like this whole burst of energy
it kind of can stand up
to the adversary kind of be toe-to-toe
with them that cliche and then he does
though like um serious like uh uh let me
just get knocked out I'm like that was
funny
that was a larious yeah I guess what
that wasn't the first three episodes was
it Tony
that was one but that was one funny
moment and also young women Rider
doesn't have powers and yet he's not a
crybaby like Beck who he gets on his
bicycle he puts on his helmet and he
goes and fights like a man and that is
why one punch man is better done so
anyways this can you talk to me sense to
this guy I mean I cried when women rider
did that so you know I I don't really
have any sense in this topic so damn it
I'm sorry I can't back it up here I
[Music]
thought the Animax stance is just I hate
whiny K a whiny main protagonists in
shown yet Shonen anime especially group
cruel yet yet you observe an Gillian was
like a Miguel yet I love the
philosophical aspect it's not my top int
in my top animes because I don't relate
to the characters as much I don't feel
the characters as relatable but that's
the thing right so again like as teens
as an edgy team you might relate to your
you know your cry-baby Dec who's and and
so and your you know your whatever the
guy kaneki from Tokyo ghoul but then
once you mature and you start to realize
that you know I want to move beyond a
high school mentality with my life why
would you relate to these people why
would you care I'm trying to understand
I'm trying to understand God Mac or not
make him understand
drop the light yes that exactly what he
said but in my words yep
oh [ __ ] come on II agree with me yeah
this is a novel thing for an cafe
everybody wait you're on the same side
as him Michael not about the whole like
P angry for the okay hold up for the
record I have no clue what's going on I
came in and I expected it to be does
Shonen anime suck and it was does one
punch man suck so I don't know what's I
don't know what's gone
not but I mean everyone relates to
different stuff just because you're an
adult doesn't mean that you have the
same adult mindset is another adult
right everyone perceived things
differently you and for my work and for
me that cliche Canada's like holds a
special place for me cuz that's most
people get into anime through gateway
shonan's you know anything watching
Naruto and spells trade so NIDA make
does like you know so that's like an
instrumental argument saying they're not
good in and of themselves but they're
good in the effect that they have on
making more and when they're good in and
of themselves just that they're also
relatable to teens who are trying to get
into it as well
yeah that's why so many people usual
site is their favorites you know is
something that is from a show and you
know like I don't watch as many anymore
because I just got tired of them after a
while but it's at the same time you know
I I could still pop in an older show
that I got into and go you know okay I
can still feel like I still feel the
momentum you can see that to when you
talk to people like it's almost you have
these type of discussions it's almost a
very different type of discussion than
what it is for another show because you
know I mean there is that personal
ground there but they're also you know
is a bit of a different investments
there's also that interpretation like
with this you know it's obviously with
Anna Mac and Tony you know there's very
two very different perspectives coming
into play that I feel both have merit in
their own right yeah and like for
example goals then my brother who's also
part of China is much more friendly
towards showing like he like really
likes my hero academia he likes a bunch
of trolls that I don't like so to me
it's like I realize that there's a
difference of pin I just I try to
understand what's the appeal well let me
you can't because you're not it doesn't
appeal to you you know you're no longer
on the demographic and you just don't
know I mean I don't find I'm going Bryn
oh well it's gonna say I've like for me
I mean I think shonan's have the quality
that you like want to root for the
character and you like get invested with
what they're doing so you know their
journey whatever it might be like
finding one piece or like whatever
becoming the greatest here or whatever
it matters it's more that's why people
get invested into it's not necessarily
about their a
teacher where they're at it's like hey
I'm investing this cool character that's
doing these things and like Wow amazing
like for me Phil Malcolm's Brotherhood
which I consider Shonen like it's a
position actually right but for me that
was like that was my gateway anime and
it was like wow I'm invested in this
character in his journey what he's doing
and so it's not necessarily about age I
don't think I don't think that really
argument doesn't really count like
anyone can watch it it's more about
where you are and like what you're
seeing the character yeah like for what
alekum as though that is a much darker
type of Annamayya it starts off with you
know their mother dying and they're
trying to bring her back and paying all
these this huge price for it right and
so it's it's I mean it's shown him but
it definitely has a lot of sane and
elements so it's again it's one of those
that breaks the mold my thing with my
hero academia being a current anime is
that I want to see where it stands out
where it breaks the mold what makes it
special and I am not seeing it oh I may
need to break the mold some anime follow
the trend and they succeed at it
yeah but book girls academia that's not
an argument for it being good that what
how's that not an argument for it being
good if it exceeds that what it does
very well then it's good like not all
anime need to break that see that's a
problem I have with a lot of people when
they make arguments about like things
need to break the mold not all anime
need to break the mold some anime just
want to be like what they're set out to
be if an anime understands what it is
and does a good job at expressing what
it is that's a good enemy you know it
doesn't have to break the mold it
follows them all and does extremely well
in it it could be cases where sometimes
you know playing it safe can result in
creating a boring show but likewise a
trying to be too original can create
something that will end up being either
too abstract or you know avoiding
certain things so now I do believe
there's there's a place for that but I
mean at the same time you know it
doesn't hurt to try and give a bit of a
twist or put a bit of a spin on it I
feel like you know sometimes a little
bit of tweak
in the right area can really give a show
or a series or a movie or anything
really a fresh take on it without you
know reinventing the wheel so to speak
yeah because to me it's like with deku
it's just like and with rented I know
it's just like this
oh I want to root for this person and
they're the underdog and they're crying
but it's like with other good shows it's
not necessarily that like look at death
no people say that's a shounen look at
death know like antihero who is Right
who is wrong we don't know there's
actual questions it's like who's the
good guy who's the bad guy same thing
with Code Geass it's like who's the good
guy who's the bad guy
Full Metal Alchemist Brotherhood - it's
a is it right to transmute a human's
what is the price um what is the truth a
scar is scar doing the right thing like
these these are like morally ambiguous
intriguing philosophical questions my
heraclea has none of that it's you know
it's just not trying to be that that's I
don't want a show that doesn't have that
because it's [ __ ] boring it's
simplistic it's weird a good guys
they're two bad guys we're gonna win you
know we're gonna win and I'm gonna
become the greatest hero what's the
point I've seen it a hundred times
before it's the journey that takes you
to that point that makes it worth it I
actually haven't seen it but I mean just
cuz just I'm gonna have to agree with
Tony on this one would it hurts me to
say because I mean I hate a glove Tony
hate three with toys Oh what this cuz
it's not something that one specific
person's gonna want doesn't mean that
there aren't other people out there who
are gonna want to watch it right I
haven't seen my hero academia it's been
on the watch list for like a long time
my train of thoughts gone holy talk okay
yeah Animax wrong there that's the
address
oh right here I hear what you're saying
I hear what you're saying but the
problem you're doing here Anna Mac is
you're projecting your style at tastes
onto an anime that already knows what
its identity is you know you can't just
go you can't go into School Rumble and
complain that it wasn't deeper
philosophical because that
School Rumble is is an emotional
comedy-drama DME that's what it's set
out to be and it does extremely well at
doing it it doesn't have to be deep or
philosophical to get that point across
an anime like Death Note is trying to
sway the balance of what does it mean to
be good and what does it mean to be evil
where's that line that's the whole
mantra of the story but with boku no yo
academia it's a story about a young hero
growing into his abilities it's not a
philosophical journey
it's basically him on a personal journey
to become the greatest hero of all time
that's the point of the story
I suppose that I should then be is
instead of that then for like
essentially the hero's journey you know
we could look at it from a different
perspective as does uh hero academia do
a good job with the hero's journey so
that's a good see that's a good question
I like that man I love you so much it's
I know that is a good question that brin
what do you think I think all shonan's
kind of have that type of a question
though like that's what you have to ask
yourself that's what makes you like it
like for example people have been
talking about hunter x hunter in the
chat which is like I mean I would say
very similar in the fact that the main
characters deku of course and gone are
very young like boys like they're kids
they're children in an essence but yet
they go on this journey they go on this
experience and they do this thing that's
a far above their abilities but yet
they're growing at the same time like
they know that they're small and they're
you know not the best but they're trying
and they're working at it and they're
building and growing and developing all
those things I just want to just put my
plug in Hunter X hundred there so that
was my plug also another great Shonen
enemy I have yet to see that I need to
see it you definitely do it's it's like
with that or like Gintama Gintama uses a
lot of uh
cliche or tropes and kind of makes fun
of different things it's a very great
balance of comedy there there's tragedy
as well it's actually
really surprising is you know I mean I
think it's AMA is a show and so I
hydronic I love show to that yes I mean
it's it's been running for a long time
that much I know for a fact but yeah
it's I mean I don't know cuz it's there
are a lot of different genres in it and
it some people classify it as such I
don't know I'm you know probably be
wrong so but uh yeah is classified as um
yes yes all right all right I wasn't
down uh cyanide it's classified as yes
got it done good prodding you know for
me Hunter x Hunter was better because
gone is not a crybaby again I like not
hard but the thing is that I realized
it's all about tastes right and I have a
different taste from Tony for example my
thing is I I think I'm a pretty big
anime fan I'm open-minded so I want to
be convinced to the merits of certain
shows like my here opinion of course my
ear cream is not even the worst offender
in the things that I don't like like I
said I watch the show rather than
dropping it and I do think some
characters are interesting in the show
are not necessarily that good to me but
there's other characters which is to it
the same thing with a like Emma Gillian
Shinji is not the most interesting
character for me but there are
interesting characters in that show to
me so I watch for that but yeah I said
just I I want to rant a bit and get to
the bottom of why I don't like certain
anime whereas you guys do for example
with School Rumble Tony I thought that
was a very entertaining anime a very
entertaining hilarious comedy anime I
enjoyed it so then why don't why don't I
enjoy my Urraca TV
I don't know I don't know but I mean
that's because you have a personal
dislike of it I mean what more can I
tell you man you can't fully embrace
something unless you're willing to see
the other side I mean see I can
understand you not liking boku no hero
and I don't have a problem with that I
see where you're coming from but you
know I feel like you in order to fully
understand somebody standpoint you kind
of gotta see where that person is coming
from and how they feel about it's kind
of like
what happened when I reviewed on
highschool DxD UH one of my good friends
and probably good friends of some of you
here Sloane the female Taku we were
talking about that show and she she
loves that show she thinks is one of the
best um Eddie anime with a plot which I
still think is quite laughable but I
understood where she was coming from and
why she saw it that way even though I
may not agree and I think that's really
how that's the only way you'll
understand the love of boku no hero
academia and why you don't like it gotta
see it from someone else's perspective
and then make a balance um stance on
that you know so it's actually really
interesting cuz I remember a friend of
mine was ranting and raving about
Kashyyyk n and I was like all right you
know this is just yeah like way back I
remember I've given you a shot I did
let's see I think mediaworks had just
released the first DVD and I remember
picking it up and I fell asleep
several episodes in I don't fall asleep
watching shows I remember just being
like this is so [ __ ] boring I live a
more interesting life than these people
do why would I want to watch people
living their day-to-day life but I could
just go out and do it and for like the
longest period of time I had like this
really difficult time accepting the
whole slice life concept it's just like
why would I watch a show where nothing
is [ __ ] happening
you know part my language but it's just
me that was literally like just my
frustration with it and it wasn't until
mushishi and keenan attabi that was like
oh you know okay I could get it a bit
more because it was a little bit more
outside of just that very dry and you
know kind of like very almost dull
serene I guess a dull is a poor choice
of word but the thing was it took me to
kind of like bridge something in there
and I was able to go back to shows like
Aria as well and I had a greater
appreciation for that because I was able
to get in that perspective more so
whereas before it's like I could
understand why people liked it but I
just thought was the like the worst
concept ever it's like why would you
watch something where nothing happens
like I go out and live your life you can
do anything other than watch the show
and it's going to be more entertaining
but then I got it after a while because
that I had that in between there so
that's not
say that's the case Anna Mac but that's
my personal experience with it so and no
I actually really loved
mushishi for example because I thought
it was like you know the great it kind
of has a great portrayal of the
relationship between man and nature and
it's just it's almost like Andrew the
art is amazing it's like a meditative
experience watching that show so I got
the show that I love even though it's
not action-packed or anything um fell
asleep watching that show it's so it was
so soothing that it just put me to sleep
I didn't hate it keep it my loved
mushishi but that show was so calming
and just like um so no I know it's true
and I and I agree with that even though
some people classify this horror I was
like you know it's creepy at times but
definitely not horror um dance in San
Asylum says that he thinks that I would
love Gundam and yeah I've seen a few
Gundam series I definitely have to see
more but I definitely enjoy Gundam and
what I like what really gets me the most
excited about anime I enjoy different
kinds but one may it makes me the most
excited is having political and
philosophical elements beneath the
surface so not just your good guys
versus bad guys but more complex
elements that make me think they make
like oh [ __ ] so that you know this is
what their motivation and their
motivation is different it's not all
good guys my guys who is the good guy
who should win you know that kind of
stuff
well I like that I got excited if you
like that I got the perfect show for you
you never heard of it it's called um
Cody gasps it's actually one of my
favorite shows the main character is Lai
Lelouch I think that's how you pin it I
called my douche cuz I use such a she's
like the douche and uh he's ec fights
the British Empire is they're called
British right British Empire and they
live he lives in a pawn yo slang and uh
it's great great anime um he's a he's a
great light impersonator I love him so
much
well you're missing the key elements
there there there's giant robots and
there's boobs like why are you not
talking about the stuff [ __ ] I forgot
about the boobs right I know
come on remember that one shot were um I
believe her name is
tan okay um Joseph for the camera and
she's like hey how about this and then
she just shows her tits to the screen oh
dude that was just a great scene wasn't
it Mac hey uh if anyone who thinks that
my hero academia can even compare to
code geass I'm not even gonna I'm gonna
have a conversation with you anymore god
those are - those are on two different
spectrums my friend sure that both
shonan's but they're on two different
spectrums when it comes to the types of
shown in the oh yeah like one shown is
not a John Burris Shonan it's a
description of an age range that certain
animes are geared towards but each have
a different genre you know
Code Geass is a war philosophical drama
whereas your academia is a fantasy
action enemy so this is you know got to
understand the genres right right rose
right rose yeah you gotta understand it
doesn't mean you need to like them
doesn't need to meet unity say Santa
like I didn't say yeah it's all Jean or
don't critique it no never never said
that basically that's I understand help
me like my hero academia I can't
understand why you like want these birds
I mean they haven't even gone to one
piece yet what's my boy like you were
saying earlier it's all about the
journey the journey I want them to reach
one piece the other thing it Luna asked
when the Q&A video is coming out goes
that still has a school for one more
week and then we're gonna have more time
so either that or before that the Q&A
video is coming out we everything is
ready we have the questions ready
artwork all that stuff the only thing
we're waiting for is for him to actually
be able to record with me and then we
gotta edit it but it's already the
questions are in the artisan so it's
coming soon don't worry I can't do it
myself
because I need him there obviously and
also I cannot do it all the editing
myself because I'm doing a lot of the
weekly regular stuff on my own now cuz
he's busier so please bear with us guys
be patient but it's coming it's gonna be
hilarious I hope if it's not and I kind
of got I kind of over his heart machine
that's why he's able to do all this I
got a question
a question for the panel uh so adam ak
actually but uh but really interesting
digging I think we should talk about um
troops in shown anatomy and the ones
that we don't like he brought up the
ones that he did it but like Briggs you
watch a lot of one piece and a lot of
others what's it looks at Ropin show
anatomy that you're not particularly
fond of would you classify fanservice
like ridiculous fanservice that takes
away from action scenes as a trope buddy
you would be both use right five I got
kind of watch some one piece here I'm
kind of watch Luffy kick some ass
and not be a whiny protagonist like
other shonan's and just like go go full
badass right and then you got Nami this
like full-on fanservice ruining the
scene sometimes Hey look at my kids just
like this story fairy tale you know
that's not possible that she has big
boobs okay you know you don't need to
insult her for figures she is who she is
Kate respect that bring everybody one's
beautiful
nobody came to my dear wife isn't acting
bad one I know you did an example I know
these dudes are complaining about sexy
female boobs
I wanna showcase all right that's a good
example then that's a good example then
of like people like different things
about shown or just like different
things about Shonen these guys like
titties ana Magda's it or no way no and
priceless I guess now we know why I like
your your eyes yeah yeah I tried United
United Matt told me something loves your
Mike thumbs up with your Mike it's like
breaking up oh that's cuz I'm up on
something okay hold on for a second just
say yeah your internet connection there
yeah um what I was gonna say something I
don't know stalk will I figure it out
guys good is lucky started no Shonen cuz
I liked lucky star
it was a great shown in episode
absolutely
[ __ ] stuff s shown yes Thank You chef
number one um what was it called a
silent voice the movie that recently
came out that was a really good shown in
as well really really enjoyed that very
epic adventure a lot of great fight
scenes Kyoto Animation the best battle
all the battles yeah so many bikes Mike
what what are some throats you don't
like in shown an enemy so um uh for me
sometimes it's in terms of like how uh
how a story will fur build on itself and
where they'll take that like for a
really really strong example I really
liked the Chunin exam in the route oh I
thought they did a great job with that
it was a lot of great action and it just
it had a really nice build to it we see
a lot of change with the character I've
kind of felt like that would follow it
afterwards you don't you don't want to
continuously go high-octane you need to
kind of pace things out by just felt
like it never really got backed that
kind of lost lost theme that's for me
personally though um you know it's like
fruit for Dragon Ball I thought that
like Reagan ballsy majin buu was sort of
a letdown after cell because I felt that
that was really big with cell and then
also just kind of stir to fizzle out
there so all my tone
yeah plot it's almost kind of plateaus
for bit that's kind of a thing that I've
noticed with some shows it really kind
of depends though um you hakusho I
thought that the dart tournament was
fantastic was a lot better than I was
expecting a tournament arcs usually are
my big problem because they'll just
randomly throw in a tournament arc to
kind of you know kill time but that was
a great example where they used it and
they actually used it to build a
character of cover depth as well um but
yeah I know it's sometimes they're able
to keep that momentum going but
sometimes it's just this sort of like
plateaus and they kind of just wind it
down a little bit but they never really
were able to get back to that point so
that's for me personally I don't know if
anyone else has that same issue though
uh one I was going to say UH one thing
Briggs for seven deadly sins what I like
about that show is that it doesn't do
the whole or you know characters
protagonist starting from nothing and
building up into something it's like the
seven deadly sins start as the seven
deadly sins
they're already powerful and it's like
so they have to actually come up with a
plot as to why they're not they're
scattered why they're not in power who
they're fighting as opposed to just oh
you're just a regular teenager and I
have to fight your way through the world
but one thing I don't like about and
it's a trope and other ones like fairy
tale force and a bunch of other anime is
that no one seems to ever die like or
they're brought back if they do and
stuff like that to me is a groundwater
way rooted yet like that's a flesh wound
I'll be fine yeah exactly and that's in
many generic shown and that's a problem
whereas with like Death Note obviously
not Code Geass obviously not full metal
alchemist people die right so so that
that's again like that's a sign of
maturity to me where you don't have
these compounds from people actually
dying in war or situations where people
are bound to die yeah I think that but -
wait yet something the bugs with
insurance is just the like like you're
saying like the invincible trope like
they're so overpowered that it's like
well I know they're nothing's gonna
happen because they're so were powered
like heroic legend of Arslan um dar Yoon
was his name yeah he was so overpowered
I'm like this isn't even fun watching
him fight like the fight scenes are cool
but like see so above everyone else that
it's not even fun anymore like there
needs to be a decent match so that kind
of bucksbeach inch on the drama
attention need to be there and otherwise
I don't work on conclusion you know
what's gonna happen exactly if you don't
have that you're gonna have a bleed
reflect no yes that is true
you don't either fix your mic bro
ah yah it was not exactly what you sound
like Jennifer you co jumped in a pool
that is accurate yes well then I will be
right back um Rose is back and uh ANBU
said that he doesn't like the power of
friendship conquers all trope well I
agree with that as well as
whoa now you telling me the heart of the
cards is bull is the heart of the cards
is the real deal it's heart of the cards
you mean we can't resolve fights with
magical dances and like hugging I
thought that's a lie right bad guys I'm
getting us call so populous all right
who wants to be in a mag who's animate
quick oh wait I choose Oh No
yes it's thee well it looks like it's
Briggs and Blizzard go back to bed
you're in America speak at the same time
so ROS ah what what role do you not like
I don't like the power of friendship so
much like uh we're about to die but just
kidding yay friendship we all survived
and we all love each other and
everything the sign in the world I hate
it so aggressive ha ha ha yes that was
very aggressive
then I'm awesome so sorry I had to take
that what's ROS doing with her mouth
nothing nothing that is secret gone I
don't know you talked to the boat ok
awesome rose so Rose your thoughts on
like this whole sure I guess I did a
good job rose yes huh
thoughts on Shana and like be there any
tropes you disliked her friendship we're
laughing cuz about that like just asked
rose that exactly I freeway that's not
ladies so you know clearly at a mine
link has been established between Briggs
and Animax oh yeah well you got Mac told
me to play Adam Axl I did it and he did
a 10 and a 10 job 11 out of 10
yeah me and I better adamak than you are
honestly so he and Briggs are starting
up a rivalry guys
so I don't know it might come to a head
when we finally meet at anime North you
know Oh fight who's the true and real
Anna Mac I'll have to solve it with the
power friendship yeah I think Briggs is
the power of friendship and Mac and I am
the animatic of all about Machiavellian
Lelouch styled strategy so we'll see the
problem here is the power of friendship
always wins one does it Oh like that you
don't have your magical transformation
there at anime North I'm gonna be pretty
disappointed this isn't the story of
like how Briggs may be like it's the
story of how Briggs overcomes the
obstacles he has to overcome them
overcome what obstacles um all of them
yes hello stone eating up Adam a cat an
amine or it's apparently a little fire
oh you're gonna fight adamak attack me
North that's it we'll be driving a car
real what model of oil instead
that's an OS my camera oops I meant the
other day camera was on how do I took
off Oh driving it straight to the
gardens of the galaxy to premiere so oh
that's awesome
the guardians of the galaxy good movie
is it yes I haven't seen the second one
obviously but the first one was a good
mood was it yeah bro because it subverts
the tropes if I remember correctly at
the beginning that little kid was uh
what was the word Oh crying yeah yeah
for the first grade oh man and I Mike
hated those first two minutes okay you
know who would cry at their mother's
death am i right would a [ __ ] cuz I was
uploading my video um it's like a stream
on my phone away you won't hear any lag
and I said you know what I fled to the
theater now too so I
why yes you're hardcore bro live
streaming too dry I don't think anyone
has done that before and that is why
Tony you are an integral member of the
rancor PHA crew
oh no I'm only here for we're here to
please break so that's it well I mean
that's why we're all in here mission not
accomplished ham
what is it swamp so now I know why I was
trying to defend my hero academia so
much but I don't know what did I miss
alone uh several people asked to roll
the same question at the same time
that's all you miss pretty much it was
the question what tropes does she
dislike and she decides the power of
friendship trope the yukio yes yeah do
they do that anymore though I can't see
a lot of shown in anime that do diamonds
not really it's kind of dumb eh be like
Brotherhood bonding kind of thing like
oh yeah we'll get over our differences
cuz you know we were buddies once that
maybe that type of thing but not like
loving hearts and transformations like
magical girls okay I could bite of that
I could buy that
yep and by the way some people in chat
we're talking [ __ ] about Kage oh I
thought KJ was absolutely hilarious a
hilarious anime very entertaining at
first I thought it was a joke too but
then when I actually watched it I
thought it was hilarious entertaining
obviously nothing philosophical about it
but again I found it hilarious and
entertaining because it had my type of
sense of humor you know in my type of
humor uh my type of plot right so I
thoroughly enjoyed that anime is that
anime supposed to be like taken
seriously or is it just one big joke oh
yeah well I thought it was a generation
I think is perfect like a anime like 8k
is a terrible anime cuz it try to take
itself seriously and not be a joke
so I'm just wondering is Keijo like very
self-aware that
it's ludicrous and is kind of like a
joke yeah 100
like Keijo knows exactly what it is it
it's hilarious because in those exactly
what it is for example they're all
training to be the schedule you know
athletes and the certain thing a subject
at school that they're learning our boob
ology and ass trolleys I think that's
about when I stop to my guy I can I
don't know I look the [ __ ] is wrong with
people that's hilarious
like how can you stop it not like I III
don't understand you I friends man
yeah okay KITT hold on I appreciated the
pun but it was just too much is like no
it's like I was like nine the point it's
over to top and that's the point in
those exact words
it's like kilakila wait a minute feels
amazing though yeah but you don't okay
way you can't compare Chile killed a guy
except it says now even here's a top
portrayal of the high school it's an
over to trough the top are traumatic of
the high school trope that's why it's
hilarious
wait a minute Mac wait a minute did you
just say that
Keijo is an anime that knows exactly
what it is and you you can embrace the
fact that it knows what it is
sounds a lot like my hero academia I
don't know who you guys is why can't to
embrace boku no hero academia for what
it is because it's not anything I don't
know what it was the man butts passing
against each other
Tony obvious like I totally forgot about
that
what was I thinking Greg's born Karnes
of the galaxy too so
oh yeah so so why you you guys are too
sophisticated feel free [ __ ] on track
the women's bodies it's not the thing oh
you guys thank you I found maybe you
like what if I'm in service one of my
good man what am i guilty than anime
come true have you seen it
I can't defend that on any sort of
serious level without sounding like a
hypocrite so yeah I understand bro
okay but I am defending Keijo it's
hilarious no I'm sure you can defeat all
you want but I want you to understand
that kick
much like boku no hero
me that understands what it is and fully
embraces that without having to do your
old philosophical [ __ ] okay but
maybe I just don't like what my here
okay Mia is that that maybe that's the
problem
you'd like I don't like it like it
adamak you just have to understand
that's the only thing that's what we're
getting at okay let's go to Brynn Brynn
how much did you like hey Joe
yeah well you know that that show didn't
watch it but I know enough about it to
not watch it cuz I just know my thing
and see like we've discussed we just
there are just some things like they it
the show knows what it is and that's
okay so I'm okay not watching that by
the way it's like you just described my
relationship with you real nice a
hundred percent off your take on K Joe
did you say me did you say me oh come on
you like a job I mean I watched a minute
of a two-minute clip and was just very
much done what is it
and like I understand what it is and I
get why people like it and I enjoy a
good pun but I just I can't I can't I
can't do that it's a little too
ridiculously so yeah like as how Ian
says but AK but kak on Titan was just a
slice of genius in there loved it
Briggs are you still here I am did you
watch Pedro I watched a couple episodes
we're still on caged oh really
I found this funny and entertaining but
I only lasted for it only last for so
long for me so basically what you're
saying is it had a fast climax is it
nice
I just I just I'm so disappointed in my
fellow ran cafe members man as we are
you I don't know just feel the love in
the air today Oh later great the power
of friendship our friendship we're gonna
solve this problem guy where's your
power
now what give you're welcome fine guys
it is true that people just have
different tastes and that's totally fine
like there's certain anime that you know
I'm a might be popular and a lot of
youtubers talk about them because
they're popular and they want the
attention to me I can't get myself to
talk about you know in in depth like one
thing is reporting news right but I
can't get myself to talk about in depth
and what anime that I don't really care
about like I talk about anime like old
yet but I really like I talk whatever
like seven deadly sins because I really
like the characters but certain anime
you know like that are mainstream and
everyone loves them but I'm not into I
can't bring myself to like like you know
Tokyo ghoul I can't bring myself like
that like I can't be myself to talk
about it in a serious way other than
just like reporting the news I but I
guess that's the beauty of difference of
opinion if you like certain types of
animatable super to like I can get into
that man it's so juvenile but the thing
is that I guess that's why there's
variety and you can go to certain people
and look at certain things I'm always
curious to see as to why I dislike
certain things that a lot of other
people like and I don't necessarily know
what it exactly it is right so that's
why these kinds of conversations I think
are useful in to try to kind of pin down
why that might be and I see in the chat
there's people disagree with me there's
people agree with me and it's
interesting to see you know why that
would be I maybe will never find out for
sure why some people have certain taste
is it a specific life experience that
they had is it that they just dislike
certain tropes but yeah I think it's an
interesting combo for sure what do you
guys think I think I hate one piece
because Berg's loves it that's a valid
reason though fair like a fair point
yeah and he also just the four kids
double out there which is the single
greatest piece of death ever created if
I don't say so myself see like I'm a kid
about lied that it came out just for the
memes this means by the way Josh
definitely wants me to notice him and to
watch food wars you got it bro you got
it food was great on their boudoirs
that's one of the best ending themes
that
you've the dope that Tony the Tony leave
us perhaps I don't know if you left this
dream or feel like if he left like if he
let y'all like guys don't streaming from
public safety announcement or service
announcement enjoy guardians of the
galaxy man the way you said it I don't
like the way you said that but hey look
if you're still around
oh okay it's not too wide this baby down
thank you guys again for joining us
everybody in the chat and all you guys
on the panel including 20 including
side-eye Buzzard have to leave a rose
let's start with you tell us a bit about
yourself and your channel and of course
great to have you back early in the
morning when you just try to wake up and
you still came on to show your support
for Rand cafe and to have pleasure
having you back on thank you for having
me it's super awesome I'm Rose I do
anime reviews I live in Korea now so
shameless Korea logs plugs there um and
yeah hi I'm still asleep it's like I
live in Korea now shameless plug for
Korea and go Korea is not sponsoring us
we're not logging Korea we only plug the
Philippines here okay ah exclusively
plugging the Philippines I got that one
by bad yo Radtke hey buddy the
Philippines country the whole attention
actually Philippines is our second
biggest demographic after the United
States on this channel I didn't know
that yep amazing yeah it's cool I'm
waiting Briggs let's go to you since
your face is back tell us who you are
and what you do I just didn't think my
computer could handle the cam apparently
kept on freezing on me but you know
gotta end it off with it
um I am all Briggs from all that yeah
I'm all the anime up Briggs from all the
anime I make fact videos I explain
concepts and animate like my hero
academia if you like it unlike Anna Mac
come by and check out my channel also I
love Shonen anime and not afraid to a
minute
yeah and Briggs says cool so another
sense in my opinion videos out right now
new ones be sure to check them out and
like I said goes and likes my hero
academia a lot my brother was also part
of this channel I have to admit he does
so I can't say that anime upper as a
whole doesn't like my hair academia and
I personally don't hate it I'm just not
in love with it that's my problem you
know it doesn't click with me that much
ah Brin let's go to you and Thank You
Briggs Thank You rose Britt Bryn for and
brains fandoms and I do anime reviews
etc doing speedpaints lately which has
been lots of fun um doing actually
weekly reviews on boku no hero academia
what the whole discussion we've been
talking about doing those on Saturday
mornings so if you want to see those as
well as just other content stop by the
channel and you know subscribe if you
want and then we can hang out there
Thank You Bryn and in your next review
video I'm gonna have a eight-point
comment where is just like Rin there is
the problem with these at this episode
we're just dissing it and that's like
respond response senpai uh then let's go
to Mackel not big mr. mr. Mack how you
doing bro I'm I'm all right I've got a
mad caffeine crash going on and it feels
awful but it's gonna work
I don't think you want that in your life
does what what school please how about
how about at anime North then you can
see it for yourself okay fine fine
hyping up the anime North blogs Mackel
not undershirt flexing you can see it
well you can watch it Wow and what tell
us about what you do Mac oh yeah I guess
I do stuff uh I don't know I mean I just
makes
if I make what I'm like it's just a lot
of it's a lot of sarcastic stuff and
sometimes I strain and sometimes I don't
upload for three weeks at a time which
is gonna be fixed this Sunday I promise
I'm so sorry but life's been crazy and
yeah and down we fix soon and there's
some pretty cool and my North's stuff
coming up in the next few days some of
which some of the people some of the
people in here are involved with I
actually have to get a hold of some of
you still for that so when do you need
that by the way you said next rider this
Friday next yeah we'll go with that
okay I got to come up with something
actually entertaining I have not so far
I've thought about it but I I mean Joe
Joe Joe's already got his in and his is
yeah I know I kind of follow that out to
follow that oh yeah it's gonna be tough
by a bunch of a bunch of satire stuff I
actually just got something in the mail
for a little for a little something
that's uh that we've been building up
for that might have a 2000 subscriber
attachment to it I don't know it might
all came in the mail whoa I'm not saying
I'm not saying it's a demon made outfit
but we'll just believe it good
but Oh Anna cosplay as RAM from re0 at
2,000 subscribers he's already over
1,900 so we need to get him to that
point so he can ruin Ram for all the RAM
fans and me and Riggs can laugh all the
way to the bank baby see I was on your
side the whole time I just wanted to
ruin it for everybody I know I know
we you're initiated and Rose is my
second youtube friend but you're my
first youtube friend Tony are you still
here with us beside you what they think
of Pocono you're like this is a man who
has commitment
he's driving and streaming his in a
theater where they specifically tell you
be quiet and get off your phone he's
streaming live what a dude one in the
police the movie doesn't start for an
hour and so I'm good okay
well of course Tony does movie reviews
animator user stuff on his channel so be
sure to check him out everyone's like is
in the description so if you don't
follow them already subscribe them
already be sure to do so however I think
I ran off a regular a config crew
already supports all the rank of a peeps
and yeah thank you guys so much for
joining me
especially Rose all the way from Korea
not sponsored by Korea though but we
still appreciate it and everyone in the
chat even the guys who disagree with me
like so maka even you guys I still
respect you and I love you I don't say
it like more that agreed with me but I
still love you as well and yeah don't
forget like go ahead sorry I keep on
trying to cut you off like guys wanna
get in there if you guys like my hero
academia watch can eg had to put it out
there watch Kenichi yep yeah there was a
guy in the chat saying Kenichi best and
I was like this this is one of those
bricks people this guy can bring us
great field definitely watch on hmm good
bad tell us why we should watch Falacci
but louder Tony what was I'm just
watching Kenichi he likes it I still
need to watch it but I will watch it
because Briggs gonna be at it he's gonna
hate oh I hate it I I was like I don't
think I could think of a person who
would hate it but I think I think you're
the person he how easily what are you
whining how much he cries in each
episode we'll see here but uh hey thanks
guys for joining us don't forget this
Sunday big discord party link in the
description of this court if you want to
join us it's gonna be crazy it's gonna
be crazy
um it's gonna be basically me getting
drunk in the talking [ __ ] about Tony
like today but even worse so yeah if you
that's all the year into if that's
something you can be sure to join us and
until next time see ya space cowboys
[Music]